[Music]
my name is Xavier decoy and my name is
Jerome do--she so today we're going to
talk about what's new in the Android
system since last year we're gonna start
with Bioware dependency management so
it's cheap last year in 300 in the fall
and you know the whole concept is that
all the value of a module can depend on
matching variants in another module so
debug depends on debug in a library and
deeper release the panel release and it
works well as long as you have matching
balance on both sides but when it
doesn't happen even though we we have a
DSL to help you fix the frame but we've
seen a lot of developer over the last
six nine months who just see you in your
message you know like this and just
don't know what to do with it so we
wanted to take a few minutes to explain
exactly what's going on and help you
solve such a problem so the first thing
to look at is does this line that say
could not resolve project library so
that's the project that publishes
artifact that you're trying to consume
and the project that's consuming it is
the one that says required by project
app and in the top right section you can
see it says you know the name of the
configuration that we are trying to
resolve which is staging runtime class
pass and it's always the name of the
valiant followed by compiler runtime
followed by class pass so here it's the
runtime class pass and the error is you
know unable to find a matching
configuration and so the way it's
working really is that the library
project is publishing a whole bunch of
artifacts for different variants in
different configuration and each of
those configuration has attributes
associated with it so that trader can
match it on the upside the request has
similar attributes and it's trying to do
a mapping and it needs to find one exact
match and here it can't find any match
so if we go through those for
configuration you know you can look at
all the attributes and basically by
process of elimination find out what the
problem is so here the first thing that
we see is two of them have you know an
API there the API used by compiled class
pass and the other two are
and you can see that the attribute name
usage we request Java Runtime and some
of them are using Java API so they are
not compatible so we can't just ignore
them then we have few more attributes
there's one here Android type attribute
that is compatible so on both sides so
we can't just ignore it it's something
that we use internally to match
different type of plug-in application
goes to libraries features so you can't
just ignore it the other one biota
attribute is not required it's actually
never required and you can just ignore
it always we use that only when we build
the model when we do a studio sync so
you can always ignore it and then we
find the final attributes which you know
is always incompatible we ask for
staging and it's finding two other
values and the name or type of the
attribute here which is package named
we'll type attribute is you know the key
part it's basically hopefully self
explanatory this is the grill type
attribute and we are requesting staging
and it's not finding it so basically it
means your library does not have the
staging will type and that's why it's
very so you can trade it there or you
can just use the DSL that allows you to
create a fallback so in that case here
on the app you're saying if staging is
not sound just use debug you have the
same exact principle if you have a
missing flavor or dimension value here
the the error message is a little bit
different because there's multiple
flavors potentially so they are named TR
being the name of the flavor dimension
but that's the same problem right it's
not finding try or when you're searching
for it and so the fix is basically
exactly the same one you're just
assigning matching fallback on the try
one and we do that on the consuming side
right on the app side of the library or
if it's a library that depend on the
library you put it always on the
consuming side you can have another type
of problem here it's saying cannot
choose between the following
configuration right so instead of
finding zero matches it finds two
compatible matches and so you know it's
only going to show the two configuration
that aren't matching it's going to hide
all the other ones so that's a little
bit easier and if you look at it there's
going to be a lot of attributes that are
compatible so you can just ignore them
and then you're down to those two here
and it says it found an attribute on the
producing side on the library but it was
not required by the consumer and so here
you know basically what's happening is
that your library has defined a flavor
dimension that is not used not defined
in the app or the consuming module and
therefore it doesn't know how to choose
this one so you can again create the
flavor dimension in your app or in the
consuming model or you can just go and
say you know missing dimension strategy
name of the flavor dimension name of the
value and all it's doing really is just
adding that attribute directly to the
request so that it's able to match the
other one and you can add these either
to the different config which applies to
all your clients you can apply it to a
specific flavor which will apply only to
that flavor or you can add it to a
particular violent thank you all right
so let's talk about some of the notable
changes that we've introduced in the
compilation pipeline the first thing
that we have changed lately is a apt -
and this is a new incremental resource
compiler and compared to a apt one apt -
is really dividing its work into two
phases there is an incremental capable
compilation phase where it's changing
your resources into a binary format and
then there is a final linking phase
where it's going to generate the
resource table and the final IDs
now if you want to use the latest
platform features you need to use apt to
and in theory apt - is entirely
compatible where is apt one however it's
a lot stricter so you might run into
issues when you change from a PT one to
a PT 2 so we have given you a flag so
that we can disable if you have issues
but you should be aware that those
issues may not be in a apt to itself it
may be in your project so you should
fight bugs if you find issues with the
apt - but you should do your homework
first you should look into well maybe
the problem is in my project
so let's look maybe you have invalid
resources and reference stuff apt to
we'll catch those so we're going to face
out a PT 1 produced
so it's really important that you switch
and that you fight bugs if you still
find some next thing is the sugar so
this is a tool which is used to remove
all the synthetic sugar that was added
by Java 8 like lambdas and stuff like
that we've delivered again into two
different versions so the first version
which ship to 3-0 was an external
process it used a lot of resource was
pretty slow now with the d8 the new
Dexter we've introduced a new version
where it's integrated inside its
pipeline so it's it's better it's faster
again we're going to phase out the old
version in theory you should all be
switching to the integrated version you
shouldn't be seeing any difference if
you do please file a bug it's most
likely our fault this time it's probably
not your fault but file a bug because
we're going to phase out the old
external process version very soon
talking about Dexter you should all be
using the new d8 compiler right now it's
was introduced in 3-0 it's now default
in 3.1 if you use DX if you still use DX
because you have elbows translation
errors or runtime errors you should
definitely find bugs they are extremely
responsive at fixing those issues and
again we're going to be facing out DX
the old DX very soon and we would like
you to be still capable of building your
applications so please fight bugs now
we've just introduced our 8 which is a
new shrinker obfuscator but it's a
slightly different thing that what it
used to be with pagada so PO got used to
operate on classifiers it was
transforming class files and making them
minified to be ready to be dext our 8
takes over the entire pipeline from
class files to text files so that means
is doing this sugar it's doing
minification and Xing all in one
operation and it can reuse a lot of
image of the data so it's faster so we
introduced it you should try it
and you should see if it works well
again please fight bugs because at some
point we will stop supporting the old
thinkers maybe not soon but very meaty
I would say now these are the flags you
can use to enable or disable r8 and d8
so please use this if you run into
trouble but please also feel five bags
okay now let's talk a little bit about
performance we know very well that it is
subject that you are extremely
interested in and so are we one of the
one of the problem we have is that we
have a lot of trouble reproducing issues
that may happen in the wild we don't
have that many implications internally
that we can use so however here is an
example using the nest mobile app and
you can see that a nest full build has
improved about you know 13% from three
zero to three one and about eighteen
percent obviously this is not final with
3.2 versus the 301 that if you keep the
same set of features in your application
obviously you're not changing the
application just changing the plug-in if
you start adding features like you know
Java 8 or Catalan you know things may
vary obviously now if you literally - if
you look a little deeper at performance
things is a little bit more complicated
so in particular when you look at
incremental builds you can see that Java
see for a full build was about 10 to 15
percent of the overall build or when you
were an incremental build it jumps to
really bad 38 percent of the overall
build time so really we can see that in
incremental scenarios Java C compilation
is the dominating factor why is that
it's because it's not incremental why is
it not incremental it's because people
are using annotation processors and so
far they are not incremental capable so
we started a joint effort with Gradle to
have incremental annotation processors
it's called in cap so it's ready it's
been shipped in 4.7 and now we are in
the process of trying to move all of
googles annotation processors to be
incremental capable there is an action
required for you from you if you have
in-house annotation processes then you
should move them to be in kept capable
to use this library it's not very
complicated for the simple annotation
processors where there
like one source file and it generates
something from one source doesn't need
to see the entire world is just adding a
few manifest entries so it's very simple
and that will eventually if all of your
annotation processors are in cap capable
will be able to switch the do
compilation to be incremental and that
will have a huge impact on the
performance of your incremental builds
thank you
let's talk a little bit about jetpack
we've heard about it a lot so how does
it work let's just take the first
example where we have a pure you won't
want to move to a pure Android X project
so here you've got your old project is
using the auto monoid support what you
should do is to use the refactoring tool
in studio to actually move your project
to use the new stuff one of the issue is
that we add some dependencies to your
project automatically so you use legacy
meta decks where you use data binding
we're going to add automatically the
multi decks report library now if you
move to a new pure Android world all the
way the X world sorry where you now
suddenly have the Android X constraint
layout instead of the old combat support
we need to know that you we must use the
other with X multi decks runtime
libraries so that the two world do not
collide right so we need to have an
indication of which one we want to
inject and you need to tell to plug in
DC's through this flag which of the two
version you want us to use okay so if
you want to move to another week's world
please use this world this flag if you
are in a hybrid world which is most
likely what's going to happen to most
people so yes you've moved your
application you moved all your projects
to use the new on Droid X stuff but you
use some external library that you have
no control over that still uses the old
combat support libraries you have no
choice you have no control over the
sources so what can you do so we're
going to provide a real-time translation
facility that will just basically change
automatically the dependency from the
old come down to it support to the new
one and we'll change the glabra itself
but by changing all the import
statements to the new ones
so this is done locally it's not like
we're gonna republish this library but
luckily you will be able to have a new
version of an pure world where everybody
is depending on the new Android X
library again there is a flag a table
jetty fire ok so let's talk about the
app vendor I'm sure you've heard about
the up under a lot over the last two
days
so we're gonna tell you a few greater
specific things so the first thing is
that on the application plug-in not on
the library or the feature plug-in but
on the application plug-in on top of all
the assemble tasks that you see here we
have rendered tasks and so you'll be
able to very quickly you know without
any change just go and build a bundle
right and remember that the bundle is a
way to upload that to the Play Store and
get out of the box much smaller apk is
targeting ABI density and languages you
know for a specific device so you'll get
much smaller instant locally you can
also build an apk exactly the same way
the Play Store does it when it creates
those apk so if you want to verify
something say you know I have a device
you know I don't want to build an apk
directly I want to build an apk to where
the Play Store would create an apk from
the bundle you can do that you know so
the step is definitely a little bit more
involved than directly building the apk
right we first build a bundle then we
use a tool called bundle tool which is
also available as a command-line tool to
create a zip of all the possibility case
and then based on a device configuration
we can go and create those apks in
general we don't really necessarily want
you to create that you know manually
using a greater task however you know a
lot of studio and Gradle itself kind of
can use that flow when you need it so
for example the install task if you have
just the basic Android application with
no dynamic features is gonna directly
build an apk as soon as you create
dynamic features which we'll talk about
in a little bit then the install task
will go through the bundle in order to
ensure that we can install that on any
device because remember if you have a
dynamic feature and you try to install
on a pre held device so API less than 21
we need to fuse that in those epic heirs
together in order to install it and we
don't want to do it a way that's
different from the Play Store we want to
do it exactly the same way that placed
orders if you try to run tests from the
command line
calling connected check it's always
going to go directly to the apks
we're gonna work later on adding support
to
you know run test yeah the bundle in
order to simulate better exactly the
type of apks that are created by the
play store deploying from Studio you
have a choice right you can either TRC
deploy apks or you can deploy apks build
the other bundle and here
the config the run configuration inside
studio has a check box that you can
check we recommend to not check it when
you do your regular development you know
as we saw earlier building a apk from
the bundle is much more complicated than
building it directly and on top of that
when you deploy from Studio we actually
look at the device you want to target
and then we inject that information
integrator and then Gradle take some
shortcuts so for example if you require
legacy multi decks which takes a while
to build but you deploy to device that's
21 or above we're actually going to use
native mutex which is much faster
we can't take that kind of shortcut when
we build a bundle so we recommend you
know to have two different type of run
configuration just create two of them
one with and one without the option and
then use the apk as often as we can and
only use the other one when you really
have to when you want to try exactly the
apk that could be delivered by the Play
Store if you push to a device again
that's 321 then we're going to use that
option anyway and we're always going to
go through the bundle as soon as you
have dynamic features so you may already
be doing manual will see apk using that
DSL and also there's a variant CPI
that'll you to compute version code you
know dynamically for the different apks
that get generated if you're doing that
right now and you want to switch to the
bundle you can just erase all of that
DSL it's completely unnecessary right
there's nothing to do all you have to do
you call the bundler task get your
vendor
Yoda and on the server side we will do
all the speed by density avi language by
default we do have a DSL to allow you to
maybe disable it if you're running into
problem we expect that there will be
very very few case where you actually
need to do that but you have the ability
if you really have to if you have that
also Firebug and talk to the Play Store
team and you know see if you can
actually solve the prime with them
so I mentioned dynamic feature earlier
so what our dynamic features right there
small AP kids that are downloaded on
demand side by side with your main apk
so if you have a feature that only 10%
of all users need no need to install it
for the other 90% just have it donated
on demand so the way you're going to
organize your code is it's a separate
sub project in greater you have a
different plug-in on you plug-in called
dynamic feature and the layout is a
little bit different compared to let's
say your library right normally in your
library your application depend on your
library and can refer the code of the
library here the features are actually
sitting on top and depend on the base so
we can see here the to base feature the
to dynamic feature in blue applying the
plug-in dynamic feature have a
dependency on the project app which is
your base one now the base one also have
to refer to those dynamic feature it
needs to list them because the way we
build the actually layer it's a little
bit complicated and unusual but you need
to list those dynamic features and it's
just a list of strings which are the
cradle paths of your all of your dynamic
features if you used instant app since
last year it probably looks somewhat
similar you know instant app you have
the feature plug-in which is used both
for your features and for your base
feature except you have a small flag
using base feature equal true but the
base feature also have to refer to all
of those features using a slightly
different DSL which is not great and
will probably migrate to the dynamic
feature version soon but right now you
do it using the future configuration and
you know you probably heard about you
know that in the future you'll be able
to instant a neighbor your app bundle in
order to deliver dynamic apps using the
app bundle and this is why it's going to
be possible because the feature plug-in
and the dynamic feature plug-in out very
very similar in fact the application
dynamic feature and feature plug-in
share probably over 95% of their code
they're extremely similar and so if
you're already architecture in your app
for instant app switching to the app
model would be exactly the same
architecture with slightly different
plugins and if you're doing dynamic
feature right now then also enabling
that to be done it instant
we'll be very similar in the future okay
so you know I mentioned that
bidirectional dependency where the a
bundle needs to know about the base app
need to know about the feature so if you
have those two modules that I had before
if you're milling the apk just look
normal right you know there's a bunch of
intermediates in each modules and each
output an apk what happens is that the
bundler task belongs to the app bundle
to the app module and so when you
actually build the bundle we have to
publish things from the feature back
into the base module and that's why we
need to have all of those dependency be
available on the base module if you
don't add a dynamic feature to your base
module it's just not going to happen
it's not going to show up in your bundle
at all so when developing dynamic
features it's important to understand
there's some differences with
traditional on the application building
so in particular there's some attributes
of your application which are invariant
which don't change between the base
module and the features application ID
version name version code all of those
should be set in the base module and we
will then publish them back to the
features so that they can be used in the
task when for instance generating the
manifest or whatever so it's important
to understand that you set them in the
base you do not repeat them in the
features we don't automatically transfer
them okay let's talk a little bit about
LTI X so let's say you are in a multi
deck situation and you're not using any
features but you're still doing the
bundle thing in this case there is
really not much difference it's the same
behavior the only difference is that
instead of shipping stuff into an apk we
are not shipping we are now shipping
into a bundle which eventually gets
uploaded the dynamic delivery will not
do much they will just take these Dex
files and store them on the on the
device before execution so same behavior
if you have feature not still not a lot
of difference basically each feature can
develop and go can become itself
multiple text files everything gets
merged
bass module and then you get all
packaged inside the bundle again and you
know same thing as without feature it
gets delivered on the phone not a big
difference by default to enabled Oh
native multi taxing now things get a
little bit more complicated if your
minions DK is below 21 so if it's below
21 we need to have flexibility to still
deliver the application in native multi
decks if you are suddenly deploying on a
device which is 25 but if you're
targeting if you're deploying on 15 now
we need to do something specific for
that and what will happen is that the
dynamically delivery will fuse all of
your text files into a single one that
will be delivered so this this is
important to realize that even if none
of your modules including the base
module or your future modules if none of
them use multi dexing itself because we
combine those into a single one this may
actually go over to the x limit and this
may a requirement indexing okay so you
need to manually enable multi tags in
the base application and what that will
do is basically create demands decklist
that it will ship along with all the
text files into the bundle so now the
dynamic delivery will take that bundle
and it will be capable that if suddenly
you're trying to deploy this bundle on a
15 device it will use the main text list
to do the fusing create the correct
method X and then create the the
extended text correctly alright
shrinking and fist acacia so if the same
as before you set it on the base module
just like the application ID so you say
minify enabled this is not a lot of
changes but how we actually implement it
is really really different so let's
let's go through the motion here first
of all this is only supported with r8
which is our new shrinker I talked about
earlier so what we do is that we take
all the rules that will be defined close
to the classes they apply to so we'll
the rules in the features we will merge
all the rules into a
then we'll take all the class files we
filled this in 208 our age will create a
combined decks big text files with
everything and then we're gonna fed that
Dex file into a Texas splitter which
will reflect these decks for all of the
features plus for the base right so it's
a very different mechanism as before now
we have again these decks is been ranked
its benefits catered now there's two
scenarios possible either you're using
the bundle or using the AP case if
you're using the bundle it's pretty
simple these text files are
automatically transferred into the
bundle like we saw earlier if you using
feature it's slightly different the Dex
files it to be republished back to each
of the feature and then they will be
packaged into the AP case all right so
it's a slightly different mechanism as
we must have said in the past there's a
lot of going back and forth and that's
why we need to have these dependencies
between features and app ok so we wanted
to talk a little bit about a few things
that actually not chipping in Twitter -
we expect we're working on it we've been
working on it for a while we expect they
will ship soon you know 3.3 canary and
they have a lot of changes and so we
wanted to kind of like give you a heads
up and also we want to feedback as soon
as it's available so I want to talk
about the way we process resources right
now in the build so if you have a first
library called library - in the current
flow what happens is that we're going to
process those resources and we're just
going to generate another Java and
nothing else
so when this gets consumed not by
another library everyone this one may be
referencing resources from library - and
so in order to really validate all those
resource references and also these will
some overlay mechanism we're going to
merge those two resource folder into a
single resource folder and process it
and then generate an order our class we
actually generate two our classes right
one is for the library itself which
library one which contain all the
resources from
a library too and then we have another
one which is just a new version of the
our class generated by library 2 that is
used in case you want to run tests and
things like that you need the final ID
version of it so then if that gets
consumed by an application we cannot
have to do the same thing again so we're
gonna re merge the amp and library 1
library 2 and process all of that and
then we generate the final resource
binary format as well as all the final
our classes that are needed by the code
from the app library 1 and library so as
you can see this is not exactly
efficient right you know this is
probably one of the last thing that is
very inefficient in the way we build
things the resources from library 2 is
basically merge and processed three
times we generate a lot of our classes
in fact we're seeing some project with a
few hundred modules generating several
thousands our classes which is too many
and so we really need to solve this so
as I said we've been working on a new
flow and this is what the new flow looks
like so first when we compile the
library to we're going to generate a
binary version of resources and this is
because apt to has that future we can't
make that work with apt so that's why
you're almost saying apt to is going
away a p2 is really the future we also
create the R class and this time we just
generate the R class directly rather
than the source code so that we don't
have to compile it that's more efficient
when we depend on it and consume it in
library 1 what we're going to do is that
we're only going to process the
resources of that budget and then we'll
use the output of the previous module
the same way basically you use a job
during Java C right it's just a compiled
class pass it's mostly there to validate
again resource references and we
generate a new resource package that
only contains those resources not the
merge version there's no much anymore
and the actor has only of that library
now that library our class only contain
the resources of that library it does
not contain the resource IDs of the
previous library and this one we don't
merge those IDs anymore
when an app
depends on library 1 a library 2
principal at the end we have an
additional step because we need to take
all those binary and the binary format
of the resources and merge it into the
final one and create the final our class
so as you can see we are generating a
lot less classes and also it's a lot
more efficient for example if I change a
resource in library to by just editing
let's say string there's no reason that
I need to compile library 1 again right
it's just the list of ideas that I need
to check against for reference is
exactly the same one there's no changes
so we can use the same thing like
comparison avoidance that we use for
Java C and then we don't need you're a
compiler very one we don't need to
recompile the app as well all we have to
do is do the finder link and that's it
and we can do that also because the our
class for the app does not use final IDs
anymore so let's look at some of the
impact of that change so first I said
that the our class of each module only
contain the resources of that module it
doesn't contain all of them that means
that if you're inside a module you want
to reference another resource from
another module you have to use the our
class from that module instead of the
our class of your app that means you're
likely to have to import more than one
our class which cut links or easily
which type Aaliyah's we are looking at
ways to also make that work in Java
easily because technically there's no
reason for the our class to be called
our it could be called whatever else so
each library could define its own name
to reduce the amount of conflicts and
again as I said you know the our class
IDs are not final anymore even in the
app to submit out to inside libraries
which means that you can to use Java
switch cases anymore
I mentioned we are not doing resource
matter anymore so if you have a module
that redefined our like a resource
already present in a library that's not
going to work anymore and there's some
good reason for that we definitely want
to hear from you if you're using that in
a strange way if what you're doing is
well in debug in my app I want to
override an icon that's coming from one
of my library you can just use by
October dependency management right in
that library have a diversion of that
icon and then the
we consume the debug version anyway
which was not the case before 300 so
that solves that problem if you have
another use case definitely talk to us
because we want to hear about it
so I mentioned namespace right you know
what I haven't talked about any
namespace so far but when you think
about it you know I just said we don't
have any resource manager or resource
for Berlin so what happens is your
application depend on the third-party
library here or third-party library here
and both of them did not declare exactly
the same resource with the same name but
with a different value you know a string
maybe or layout or Nikon or something
like that in the past the resource
merger would just pick one of them
basically the first one that you defined
in your dependency would have a higher
priority and it will just merge on top
of the other one and it would just
replace the other one which is probably
not what you want and so here what's
happening now is that where if we really
want to do is you want to package both
of them so both of them are going to be
compiled in their own namespace and then
we're going to package that internally
the are classes from those two libraries
will have different we'd have the same
you know our dot string that foo but
with different values and internally in
the resource table that will really
point to two different resources which
is much better so now when you refer to
a library to a resource from a library
you have to use the namespace of that
library and using the our class of that
library is already a way to access it
the i'ts namespace right it's like you
don't have a single our class with all
the IDS so when you do that from the
manifest it'll be different you have to
use the manifest though when you start
from XML you have to use the namespace
directly in the resources so at from
doctype every one colon string slash
text which is very similar to when you
access an android namespace resource
right at Android colon something if you
do have custom attributes you have to do
the same thing so you're probably using
res Auto everywhere now not really
bothering
what's your name spaces now you actually
have to care you can say hey you know
this is construct layout these you know
this XML prefix constraint is that
namespace of that library and then I can
use those attributes so we're hoping to
bring that in 3.3 canary it's good
obtain obviously some breaking changes
we're gonna legal that with the flag
we're going to include refactoring
supporting studio so that you know all
those reference will be changed for you
and we're going to want a lot of
feedback right it's not going to be
turned on in 3.3 final by default either
there's going to be several revision
where there will be you know changes and
improvement but will want a lot of
feedback thank you okay let's think we
want to talk about today is our public
API we are painfully aware that the
public API that we provide is not very
good it has very poor documentation the
puggly the plug-in DSL is pretty bad
it's not specific to the module type so
there's plenty of things you cannot set
in different modules
yet the DSL is still there there's no
mechanism to access the intermediate
files so some people would like to have
access to the merge manifest class files
Dex files you name it you can't really
do it in a nice way the variant module
doesn't give access to a lot of
information coming from the variant
properties so you only have access to
part of the truth and then this is too
many things that require internal API is
hacking tasks the perfect separation
between public and internal API is not
well defined so you don't know when
you're switching from one to the other
so it's a mess and to give you an
example this is how the configuration
works today right so we have the DSL
passing first and then we create a
variant right so that bunch of variants
are created then we test we create of
the tasks both of these variants and
eventually we call the VAR e on TV I so
that's where a lot of the scripts
customization scripts are running but
you can see here the the problem is
right there is right in front of you
that it's happening after the tasks have
been created so there's no way you can
change anything that will influence
tasks creation say you want to switch
from legacy multi decks to native multi
decks but you can't do that anymore
because we've already created the tasks
for legacy multidex say you want to
change some of the information in the
DSL programmatically instead of putting
it in the DSL
why you can't really do that either
because we already created the tasks
chances are that the input have already
been finalized so it's happening too
late and then eventually the after
evaluate scripts the customer wants run
even later so there's really no way you
can do a lot of things here and so what
people do is that they access the tasks
and then they try to figure out where
the files are generated and estimates so
what we would like to do is to have a
simple gradual API interfaces that would
be the only module that you should
depend on and if you stop depending on
some about all the modules like other
core you should talk to us and you
should tell us what are your needs what
are you are you doing this don't think
that we are not listening we are
interested in figuring out why you need
to customize things and we are
interested in providing you a good
solution so one of the thing we are
looking for for instance is to give you
access to all of the intermediate files
so each intermediate file really is
associated with the type right you've
got classes you've got merge manifest
you've got text files of that resources
all of those should be able to be
accessed and should be safely capable of
being replaced so you should be able to
say give me the menu the merge manifest
change it a little bit and I'm giving
you back at this new version and that's
the one you should use to continue the
build process so it should be
replaceable it should be a tangible
maybe you want to add class files
directly and eventually all of this
should be drawn through very
well-defined extension points so we
started working on it and we would like
to have feedbacks on this so the
proposed phases would be slightly
different now you've got the dsm passing
we would then start invoking new custom
code right there so you would have the
ability to stop changing dsl objects
programmatically even before we start
creating variants then we would lock
them up that means you can change them
anymore
once that code has run it's locked up we
would then create a variance from this
information from the variant we can then
call directly the variant API so that's
the ability for you to change variant
related information
now we aware that this is happening
before the tasks creation right there's
no task created yet so this is really
the ability to say it was using multi
decks no I wanted to use negativity
decks once these very otps scripts have
run we will lock up the valiant a object
so again if you use crits later on lucky
enough to evaluate that starts to change
the DSL parsing or the variant it's too
late we will not allow it to will throw
an exception then eventually we create
the task and we will lock them up
immediately we will not allow you to
modify the tasks anymore the way to
modify things will be to go through the
buildable artifact to inject to replace
to a pant but not mocking with the tasks
because we replace them all the time we
merge them we delete them we split them
whatever we need to do to support new
features or make things more efficient
and unable to lead after a very it will
run so the compatibility will be a
painful subject we will try to make
obviously the DSL mostly unchanged we're
going to try to make an effort to also
becoming more content friendly and
unfortunately we think that the variant
API will change heavily but since we
already realize that it was not so great
hopefully you'll be sympathetic to the
idea that you will have to change the
script using the variant API so we want
to hear from you it's very important
that we get feedback from the community
for us and I want to thank you for
coming tonight I know it's a late
session it was very nice to see so many
people here tonight thank you
[Applause]
[Music]